well as Dominic robbed the Foreign
Secretary's last night the government's
working to repair II had tens of
thousands of British citizens who are
stranded abroad but has urged those who
can to book commercial flights home
while they're still operating those who
are stuck say getting home isn't their
only problem they're also struggling now
to secure basic necessities food and yes
even water let's turn to Michelle fuller
and Lisa Britain they're stranded in Goa
in India and they join us now as you see
welcome to both of you and thanks for
joining us Michelle if I can start with
you I understand you would you to fly
back last week what's happened since
then no no I actually I'm just like that
on the 12th of April we're out here for
three months we came out in January but
we keep getting flight cancellations
although we're not be flying we we've
had emails sustainable financing
democracy we person news the India of
both the borders and there's no likely
either going out so for the last week
I was beautiful I home on the 26 and I
could get as far as at first they told
me Oh India that I could take the flight
Mumbai I could get the Mumbai but from
Mumbai there was no like take me back do
you pay then I get another message
saying all internal flights of thought
then no tact is also no trains no buses
and all food clothes which has been very
difficult for all of us every day going
out there have you got to mark those do
you have a banana and I buy anything
I have money it's been difficult and
standing in queues for hours and hours I
have pictures of this and not just me
but Indian people as well no food coming
over the border from cannot occur no
fresh food we're very fortunate there
because we've been told that we can stay
here for as long as it takes to get this
home which isn't the same for a lot of
people that have been wandering around
locked so we're very lucky and the
people that they're hosting us here have
made rice and daal every day so we've
had something to eat though we're really
fortunate compared to some people yeah I
hear you Lee certain there's going to be
people in less fortuitous circumstance
exactly that's for sure Michele I mean
we're hearing reports because of the
curfew will not the curfew they thus the
the the the ban on movement for inaction
yeah 1.3 billion people some people
reports of police brutality are you
getting in a sense of how difficult it
is to get out and buy necessities if you
need to I'm equally self NGO community
though of paradise and dreams and going
2020 and they've been really helpful
that the only communication really that
we've had I've been in touch with
Dominic EE rather the phone secretary
I've been in with my local MP
LM what they personally and they spend
the outside is going outside is become
intimidating in the fact that we asked
Breton's by the police with then we got
told that they were spending on policing
also you're not supposed to go to the B
basically it was like just walking to
the shop they say no driving though you
walk was shot accused in the heat of the
day three hours long you can be hearing
and then they just shut the shut there
nobody else get served only three people
in this guy nobody is allowed in the
shop they draw white where's his balls
of separation there's just bleed
everywhere they've got road blockade
it's very intimidating you know not to
be able to just have the basic
necessities that you need in life sad to
say you don't have to spend very long
online to see you know some of the usual
keyboard warriors being rather callous
and saying well hang on a minute
if you elect to go to a country in the
midst of a crisis you may find yourself
in in difficulties what would you say to
those people
well we wasn't in the midst of the
crisis
I went on January 13 and there was no
problem there it was heard this news and
then we tried to clone an airline
company is Air India and we just not
getting anything
understood anywhere yes Brian May
the best and do what we can and they
seem to be making up rules by the but
it's been like every half an hour there
was changed the rules go out between six
and ten
there's Brian's fine food and then
they've changed the rules again but
nothing would be open it's been these
hours I am sitting to you after Keith
just being shut down
there's no food and so have many Indian
people as well it's not just the British
the Dutch the French the Germans and all
these nationalities it is also the
Indian people that are suffering with
this all snow here in South Goa well
Michele fuller and Luther Britain we
wish you both very well and safe journey
back as and when that can be organised
for you